the stupidity you are witnessing
is real the special people's court
judge wendy is in her chambers and she
is eating up a storm
first of all is wendy fit to be a judge
wendy you are officially [ __ ] right
yes right i'm half retired and half
human you're half [ __ ] half human
yes yeah your mom is human and your
dad's [ __ ] yes
and when they made it it made a half
[ __ ] person and a half human
yes yes all right that's all we wanted
to know thank you first of all let me
explain the case to you okay wendy
fred the elephant boy reported
high-pitched eric for threatening his
life via social media and texting
now uh judge wendy is gonna need to
decide whether high-pitched
threats broke the law and are punishable
in our special people's court okay this
is the defendant
high pitch eric he's currently having
trouble fitting through the courtroom
door
this is the plaintiff fred the elephant
boy we can hardly understand what the
[ __ ] his claim is
all right so why do you continue to
tweet
what is going on what is that wendy what
are you doing
oh i would stick a drink of my mountain
dew and wet
up my nose
can you lay off the mountain dew yes
all right hi pitch what is your opening
statement
i know i threatened fred you did you he
wasn't committing to
yes that's all for yes all for no i
never
meant to do that and you're my son
to do that but here's what i don't get
elephant boy if i can jump ahead a
little bit
elephant boy isn't making statements of
his own but he's retweeting negative
tweets about eric on his account
why provoke him you say if somebody
threatens my
love i get to be a little but i'm trying
to get him to back off and you keep
provoking him
leave him alone i have to consider it's
not that
uh judge wendy what do you think of what
he's
mummering here yeah i cannot quite uh
understand his mumbling
well can i say something to you eric
yes are you what are you again feeble my
iq is like a 64.
all right do you really think he is a
physical threat to you
one of the texts and accept me
is that i have people coming to your
address do not watch your back
oh you get that beat down
do you have any evidence you want to
admit now and say here's how he provoked
you so he said to this day
whenever i ask hpe what they said about
his mother
he refuses to answer
and you know i don't have to answer to
to my mother you know what i mean who's
reading his tweets anyway two
three people no is fred within his
rights
to keep tweeting whatever he wants all
right let's
get a ruling on that wendy yes
i forget all rise
and [ __ ] your pants for the honorable
judge wendy
all right i think everybody has it yeah
yeah sure
wendy it is time to rule well um
high pitch i have to say i really do
love you and i really do have good times
with you whenever i'm up there or
whatever we do
but um elephant boy is right
you need to uh get a little bit of help
and not you know
threaten so many people eric the ruling
has gone against you
she can take away your flat ronnie and
make you return it
that could be one penalty or she could
send you to
what we call special people's court gas
chamber
where will the farter comes in and he
farts all over you
i like the will of the father
you want wendy to rule in the favor of
will the father
i think i could deal with that all right
wendy let's get to sentencing
yes ronnie yes move forward and do the
farting thing yes
you want him farted on and you want him
to get back flat ronnie yes
she went [ __ ] crazy through the
bucket that's the
authority to
baffling case
walking all right it's time for the gas
chamber will
are you ready a little closer that's
right [ __ ]
it smells like horseshit
he's taking it he's taking it
eric are you ever gonna threaten
elephant boy again no